Let's go through the answers together.
For sentence 1, this open tag for bold--bold Baroque music!--
must be paired, must be balanced with a closed tag for bold.
That looks like this. It's the left-angle slash token.
Then the bold closes off.
Down here Johann Sebastian Bach was--
this looks like the beginning of an italics tag,
and you see that we're closing it off later.
For this to be valid HTML, we really need to make this a well-formed tag.
Johann Sebastian Bach was German.
In fact, he was born around 1685 and is known for his fugues.
They repeat in a structure that's actually surprisingly similar to regular expressions
or context-free grammars. More on that later.